isla castner also known as the occultist
was born in 1932 to father castner a
priest in brookfield connecticut we know
this based on father castner's photo
album that he shows to lorraine warren
not much is known about isla's mother
except for the fact that she died during
childbirth this led father kastner to
make the decision to raise isla in
secrecy in an old mill at the edge of
town where the church wouldn't find her
he made this choice because
understandably the church would probably
have a lot of questions about how a
priest who took a vow of celibacy
suddenly has a biological child and i
think claiming immaculate conception was
probably out of the question though i do
kind of wonder why he wouldn't just
claim that he found the baby and offered
to take her in it's not like paternity
tests were common in 1932 but maybe it
still would have looked suspicious if
they looked alike secret romantic
affairs were not father castner's only
hobby he became obsessed with the occult
and for much of isla's childhood she
witnessed her dad studying satanist to
try to stop them from spreading their
evil his interest in studying the occult
combined with isla's confinements to
where those occult objects were kept
ended up creating a perfect storm that
led to isla becoming the exact type of
satanist that father castner feared to
find out how isla became an occultist
who dedicated her life to an evil curse
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by audible
welcome to horror history in this lesson
i'll be covering the life atrocities and
death of brookfield connecticut's most
deadly satanist isla castner or as i
sometimes call her the malnourished lady
before isla's birth the church had been
using an old mill by the river just
outside brookfield connecticut for
storage as father kastner put it it's
where they put the things that they were
afraid of things they didn't understand
leaning into the metaphor he thought
this would be the best place to raise
his illegitimate daughter in secrets
when i say it out loud it kind of makes
sense that isla turned out the way that
she did since father castner raised isla
in secret it's safe to assume that she
was homeschooled and wouldn't have been
allowed to have any friends except for
maybe her dog petey either way isla
couldn't have had much socialization
with other kids or anyone besides her
dad while father castner didn't seem to
think this was a problem
it was just the two of us
our happiness filled this house isla
seemed to have a different opinion
having to be hidden away from the world
and shame along with her father's
obsession with satanism made for a
deadly combination as isla grew up with
a thirst to get back at the world that
she had been shunned from in order to
understand the deadly curse that she
dedicated herself to we'll need to take
it back to before she was even born
[Music]
when cults are mentioned in the
mainstream lexicon they're usually
associated with the 1970s this is
because some of the most infamous and
destructive cults were brought to light
during that decade one of the most
prominent being charles manson and his
followers you feel blame
are you mad uh do you feel like wolves
kept replenishing your friends
[ __ ] british
however cults had been feared by
civilians for centuries before this
according to penn state humanities
professor philip jenkins there are cults
on record that date back as far as the
late 1800s however it wasn't until the
early 1930s when the earliest recorded
anti-cult movements began as new
political and religious groups started
to form there was a backlash and many of
these groups were speculated to be cults
of satanists who promoted devil worship
the media of the 1920s really ran with
this idea and both the christian and
catholic sex of the church found these
groups to be particularly threatening so
this is where father castner's concern
about these cults started even prior to
isla's birth he was likely spending a
lot of time with the mill as he studied
these groups after isla's birth in 1932
she grew up in isolation instead of
doing the things that a kid would
normally do like play with other
children or eat food isla explored the
tunnels below the mill becoming very
familiar with them meanwhile at home her
father's office was littered with cursed
items from different satanists that the
church had investigated even if father
castner had tried to keep isla out of
his office where these items resided she
inevitably would have still found her
way in to explore just as judy warren
later did at edin lorraine's locked room
of cursed items
honey what are you doing
come here
you know better
like judy isla would have been curious
about what her father was spending most
of his time doing and about the unique
items that filled his study the
difference is that growing up judy had
three adults to look after her isla had
one where judy had other outlets to be a
normal kid like roller skating with her
babysitter or raising the chickens isla
really only had her father and his
obsessions as father castner would later
state himself i continued my studies
into the occult i wanted to protect her
from all this
but instead i created
a fascination as the anti-cult scare of
the 1940s started to die down isla
entered her late teens and early 20s i
would credit isla's virtual isolation as
a child leading her into a life of
rebellion and desire to break away from
her father i mean plenty of teenagers
try to rebel against their parents and
form their own identity without having
been confined to a secret hidden life
but where most young adults leave home
to form their own identity by going to
college joining the army dating some
lunatic their parents don't approve of
dying their hair some ugly color getting
tattoos or even subscribing to sissy's
world ayla took what she had become most
familiar with the occult and ran with it
i isla's life from 21 to 49 years old is
left mostly unknown father castner
implies that she disappeared stating
after all this years i thought she'd
come back to me again in the last
documented photo of her she's 20 years
old in 1952. because it's the last photo
she must have disappeared around that
time prior to her disappearance father
kastner describes her fascination with
the satanic information he had been
studying so it's likely that she
followed one of the many occult groups
that she learned through the text and
cursed items in her dad's office there
were many to choose from so it's tough
to say with certainty which one she
would have chosen however based on what
the warrens and father castner learn
about what isla had been working on it's
possible that she didn't go very far
away at all
the conjuring films are based on the
case files of the so-called
demonologists ed and lorraine warren the
couple had a long literary career before
ever being featured in the conjuring if
you want to dig deeper into their
paranormal adventures the best place to
start is with audible audible is the
exclusive carrier of the warren 6
audiobook set detailing stories not told
in the films audible offers an
incredible selection of audiobooks
across every genre including horror
you'll also discover exclusive audible
originals from top celebrities renowned
experts and exciting new voices in audio
members get a free title every month for
keeps plus there's a great selection of
free podcasts this month i'm listening
to salem's lots the stephen king vampire
story that i haven't read since middle
school so it's almost like i'm reading
it for the first time to try out audible
premium plus free for 30 days visit
audible.com cz's world or text cz's
world to 500 500 you'll find that link
in the description audible.com
cz's world
father castner studied many cults but
one that occupied most of his attention
was the disciples of ran this is the
same cult that annabelle higgins was
part of when she and her boyfriend
butchered her adoptive parents and
attempted to kill the neighbors under
the control of the demon malthus if you
want to know more about malthus check
out my horror history episode on malthus
which goes into more detail but did isla
join the disciples of ram or just take
influence from that to answer this we'll
need to look at the timeline from what
we see in annabelle the cult has gained
enough notoriety to become a concern to
the general public around 1966 when
annabelle higgins left her family and
similar to isla disappeared ila left
home in 1952 so it's unlikely that she
would have joined this specific group
because father castner probably didn't
start studying them until the 1960s plus
the demon that isla summons later is
definitely not malthus but we'll get to
that isla really could have traveled
anywhere to investigate any of the
occult items or groups that her father
was so afraid of but it's also very
likely that she was living in the
tunnels below the mill for the last few
decades it would at least explain why
she looks so malnourished and pale
throughout the 1970s assuming that she
had access to any newspapers radio or
television she would have witnessed her
dad's fears come to fruition as some of
the most destructive cults were revealed
the charles manson family was caught in
1969 and the jonestown massacre occurred
in 1978. these cults may not have been
satanic cults at least not directly but
regardless concerned mothers and perhaps
unintentionally the beatles amped up a
nationwide panic that father castner had
dedicated himself to preventing all of
this set the scene for the 1980s
[Applause]
to describe this story as horrifying
would be an understatement satanism
devil worship is being practiced all
across the country
devil worship exposing satan's
underground to summit to religion to
others it's the practice of evil in the
devil's name
it exists
and it's flourishing there's another
attack upon our society yes there's a
vast movement toward the occult within
the cartoon and toy industry
those represent the horns of baphomet or
the horns of satan how could this happen
to you
to a nice boy from a good catholic
school and a fine middle-class family is
it the church's position that demonic
possession is possible it certainly is
the satanic panic of the 1980s was
basically a repeat of the anti-cult
scare of the 1940s the event that really
marks the beginning of the satanic panic
was a book called michelle remembers
which was written by canadian
psychologist lawrence pastner with his
patients and then later wife two titles
that should probably not go together
michelle smith about her scarring
childhood memories in a satanic cult
while the validity of this book has
since been debated it was widely popular
and sparked a media frenzy fanning fears
and sparking many allegations of
satanism if ayla had any access to the
media at all during this time she would
have been exposed to this moral panic
which was directly associated with the
church due to her position isla already
had it ingrained to associate the church
with shame and resentment according to
the new york times early in the 1980s
baseless conspiracy theories about cults
committing crimes against children
spread around the country the way that
father castner speaks about the
disciples of rem alludes to this
phenomenon they defiled holy land with
their obscene rituals and
they committed acts of blasphemy
with years of built up resentment
towards her father and the world around
her this outbreak of alleged satanic
activity gave isla the motivation to act
on her occult findings in her late 40s
she discovered a curse from a section of
witchcraft called the stregaria the
stregaria is a practice of witchcraft
originating in northern italy it was a
modernized paganism and most of the
incantations are spells aimed for a
bountiful harvest season or wishing for
a loved one to return home safely from
travel but isla found a much more
specific and darker curse my latin is
rusty but
i think this
is talking about human sacrifice
one by murder and the other by suicide
whether isla really did leave home to
discover the strogarea or if it was one
of the many texts in her father's study
she figured out how to perform this
curse and put it into action in may of
1981 just before she was set to turn 50
years old isla built a large stone altar
in the tunnels under the mill which i
have to admit is really impressive
considering it looks pretty heavy and
she probably only weighs about 40 pounds
herself on the altar she carved a
pentagram and lined it with black
candles through this curse isla could
perform a ritual at the altar allowing
her to take possession of other people
she lights the candles around the
pentagram with a chalice in the middle
then cracks an egg into it and lights it
on fire before drinking from it probably
the most protein she got the entire
month the curse requires isla to connect
to the subject that she wants to control
in order to offer their soul to the
demon that she summoned she does this by
putting a physical witch's totem in that
person's possession or on their property
isla makes her own totems out of the
jaws of animals and other natural
materials i'm guessing she got the
animal skulls from livestock in the area
and this may also explain where she's
been getting food from and where she got
the eggs for her ritual it's not exactly
clear how or why isla chooses her
specific victims we can only assume that
she surveyed the people of brookfield
and chose those who fit the profile
needed for the curse to work we
eventually learned that this curse
requires a human sacrifice one by murder
and one by suicide so she targets a pair
of unsuspecting college students jessica
strong and katie lincoln isla could have
hidden the totem somewhere in jessica's
dwelling at the college or she might
have tricked her and given it to her
directly whatever the case may be
jessica must have thought her totem was
something interesting rather than a
dangerous witch artifact because she
brought it home with her to danvers
massachusetts unintentionally allowing
isla to take control over her
[Music]
after placing the curse on jessica
strong isla was able to see everything
she was doing late one night jessica
brings her friend katie lincoln to
explore the forest and with the two
isolated from many spectators isla took
control of jessica and proceeded to stab
katie to death when jessica came to and
realized what she had done she ran away
in a panic in the dark leading her
straight off the side of a cliff where
she fell to her death technically the
murder and the suicide had been
fulfilled the next part of the curse
involved the sacrifices of three more
people the child the lover and the man
of god first she would go after the
child which brought her to the glatzel
family who had a young son
eight-year-old david glatzel and were in
the process of moving into their new
home in may of 1981. before they even
began moving in she placed a totem under
the house directly below the child's
bedroom david started to exhibit strange
behavior and signs of possession so as
we've seen many times in the controversy
the catholic church soon got involved
and the paranormal investigators and
lorraine warren were called in to hell
they were able to get the approval of
the church to send a priest to perform
an exorcism on david on the night of
july 18th 1981 father gordon came to
perform the exorcism with the assistance
of ed and lorraine only in this case the
exorcism got way out of hand and
ultimately was not successful thanks in
some part to the visions that lorraine
had connecting her to the tunnel where
ila was performing the ritual from these
visions seem to cause physical pain to
lorraine and ultimately young david
whose demonic possession is being
channeled through isla breaks free and
attacks ed in an effort out of
desperation the boyfriend of david's
sister arne johnson willingly offered
his soul to the demon in an attempt to
save david
alone
[Applause]
since arnie was connected to both david
and his sister debbie glatzel taking
control of him would grant access to the
child and the lover arnie and his
girlfriend are in love and constantly
expressing physical affection prior to
arnie's possession because he willingly
offered his soul isla wouldn't need to
place a new totem in order to possess
him the evil goes dormant inside of him
so everyone lets their guard down for
the time being believing that the
exorcism was a success however it would
not be long before arnie would start to
notice visions of isla who eventually
takes full control of arnie and
possesses him to kill his landlord
brunei the warrens figure out that arnie
is still possessed and try to provoke
the evil entity inside of him by setting
up religious objects such as the cross
and having him read from the bible which
he surprisingly does with no problem
however the warrens are operating under
the assumption that his possession would
follow the same rules as previous
demonic cases that they had dealt with
like malthus who would be averse to holy
objects what they seem to overlook is
that it's not actually the demon that's
directly taking possession of him it's
isla herself that makes this case more
similar to the enfield poltergeist case
in 1977 where a girl named janet hodgson
was possessed by the non-demon valik but
lorraine wasn't able to detect valik
because it was using the ghost of an old
man as sort of an intermediary isla also
uses a different tactic at times when
she takes possession of people she'll
give them visions of horrifying
creatures threatening them this leads to
the possessed people to react by
attacking the people around them
personally i wonder why she does this so
often instead of just taking direct
control of her victim like she did with
david this is one of those cases where
the conjuring lore isn't really that
clearly defined and we have to make our
own assumptions the best guess that i
can come up with is that the rules of
the curse that she's trying to perform
require that her victims carry out the
actions themselves so for example when
she needs jessica strong to end herself
she can't just take control of jessica
and run off the cliff she has to scare
her into running off the cliff on her
own however she does later attempts to
get rid of arnie by literally just
taking control of him and having him
slit his own wrists but maybe that's not
part of the curse maybe she was giving
up on arnie as a vessel at that point
because she didn't like lorraine being
able to see her through her victims
otherwise you would think she would have
just done that to all of her victims to
begin with or maybe she just enjoys
tormenting her victims and seeing them
react that's the easier but less fun
explanation as i alluded to when isla
initiates the curse she didn't
anticipate the warren's involvement and
their investigation throws a significant
wrench into her plans adam lorraine
investigated the funeral home that
jessica strong is resting at where
lorraine due to her abilities is able to
see through isla's point of view
[Music]
by the blood of calvary i command that
isla is surprised by lorraine's psychic
visions but doesn't seem too afraid of
her
how are you doing this god has shown you
to me and your god is damned you in
addition to possessing living people
isla can also possess corpses
temporarily giving them life because
apparently she can just do that
good to know as she discovers lorraine
watching her via the psychic connection
she takes control of a big boy in the
morgue sending it to attack ned is able
to pull her reign out of her vision just
in time if you're interested in the
mechanics of this look at it like this
lorraine was looking in on isla by
touching her previous victim jessica now
that the connection is formed isla can
look back at lorraine as long as
lorraine is still touching jessica and
isla can control other things in the
room while the connection is still
established when lorraine lets go of
jessica the connection seems to be
broken up and isla loses control of her
big boy and he collapses the cleaning
crew in the morning is going to be
really confused but ayla sees ed who is
already vulnerable due to his poor
health as a potential tool to get rid of
lorraine not only would this leave isla
unopposed but i imagine that lorraine
could have checked off the box for the
lover for her evil ritual due to
lorraine's unwavering love for her
husband she sends a new totem to the
warren's house disguised as a bundle of
flowers and her assistant drew
unknowingly brings it inside it's not
out of the ordinary for the warrens to
receive gifts from the families that
they had helped in the past this allows
isla to take control of ed who also
gives her access to see into the
warren's house and view all of their
research she seems to be taking a
particular joy in possessing ed by
taunting him oh don't worry mr warren
you're so close i'd hate for you to give
up now
once again using the tactic of
encouraging her victims to do the dirty
work by giving them misleading visions
she gives at a vision where he's being
attacked by the bloated possessed big
boy from the moor causing him to grab a
knife and try to fight bat he is just
barely stopped by drew before actually
stabbing his wife together they find the
totem and remove isla's ability to
access or control isla knows that the
warrens are closing in on her and they
now know how to stop the curse by
destroying her altar if they can find it
so she must enact the end of her curse
fast if she wants to succeed to make
matters worse for her lorraine goes to
father kastner for help translating the
straga real having no idea that she's so
close to isla and her altar as she does
so father kastner also reveals that isla
is his child and that he is aware of
what she's up to but he couldn't bring
himself to turn her in because she was
his daughter and he still loved her i
would assume that all of these
sentimental feelings are not mutual
however because as soon as lorraine
leaves hilah pays her father a little
visit
as father kastner prays for forgiveness
for his failures as a priest and as a
father he's cut short when eilich coldly
slashes his throat not even giving him
the time to utter his final words this
action whether she planned it or not
fulfills the man of god part of the
curse bringing her one step closer to
winning if she managed to kill lorraine
no one would be there to stop her from
killing a child to satisfy the last
requirement of the curse however she
knows that she's in real trouble because
if lorraine destroys her altar in time
the whole plan will be broken up luckily
for isla she made her alter out of stone
and lorraine can't move it on her own
she reaches and attacks lorraine
specifically she tries to stab lorraine
in the eye in both a literal and
figurative attack on the reign's psychic
visions that have been the cause of
concern for isla so far but it is
lorraine's psychic ability once again
that saves her because she's able to see
herself through isla's point of view and
it is only there that she notices the
rock that she uses to smash the
occultist and break free when ed arrives
to save and protect lorraine isla once
again takes possession of him by
blowing dust in his face it seems like
they're just making rules up at this
point but i guess maybe that was like a
ground-up witch's totem who knows at
this point honestly let's just roll with
it when isla takes possession of a
person she works the same way a demon
does in that she can split her attention
between the possessed individual and her
own selves we saw this in annabelle
creation where the horned demon malthus
could terrorize people in one location
and the possessed janus would come after
people in the other room isla uses this
technique to her advantage by sending ed
after lorraine with the mallet to
distract from her returning to the altar
to take control of arnie one more time
she starts the ritual with arnie's photo
as he arrives in pain under isla's
possession she gets him to pick up a
shard of glass and hold it to his own
throat luckily for arnie his girlfriend
holds his arm back while the priest goes
into some prayers to try to rid him of
his possession meanwhile as ed attacks
lorraine she pleads with him to remember
their first kiss she tried to turn you
against me
because she thinks our love is our
weakness but it's not
these words get through to him and he's
able to regain control of himself and
smash isla's altar carnival style
breaking the curse and releasing arnie
from isla's control
your curse is broken in the end
lorraine's ability to get through to ed
was fitting it was supposedly their love
that helped them defeat isla and she was
not able to stop them because she didn't
know love as the illegitimate daughter
of a priest she lived an isolated life
where her only family looked upon her in
shame although her father may have cared
about her she was blinded by resentment
the malnourished lady was also
malnourished from love but even with her
master plan literally having crumbled
before her isla emerges from the dark
with a knife in hand looking like she's
going to use it to take revenge on the
paranormal couple that had ruined
everything for her before getting the
chance to do this the demon she had
summoned finally arrives in a corporeal
form it is not clear who this demon is
we only see it in the form of isla
herself to me this suggests that the
identity of the demon doesn't really
matter because isla is the true evil of
the story that it possessed each of the
victims so far unlike the previous
conjuring movies which draw lore from
the old grimoire the lesser key of
solomon which appears as a book called
the devil's welcome in the first
annabelle movie the dark magic conjured
by ilo was inspired by the italian
concept of stregaria which is just an
archaic word for witchcraft there isn't
a specific roster of demons associated
with it so the warrens see this demon in
the form of isla as it twists and
contorts her before finishing her with
this
[Music]
ed explains that she promised this demon
a soul and it would not go back to hell
without one and that concludes today's
lesson on the occultist isla the
malnourished lady click the playlist on
the left for my analysis of other evil
entities in the conjuring universe like
bathsheba malthus and valine and
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring the death
bell and select all notifications and i
will see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
[Music]